this video is sponsored by Skillshare
everyone knows that humor is important
it permeates our entertainment is a huge
part of social conversation builds
friendships and romantic relationships
affects culture and so on
however despite it being everywhere this
seemingly rare that anyone thinks much
about why what it means to laugh and why
we like to so much and how this simple
involuntary cackle of the voice can
influence so much of the world 20th
century American writer EB White said
that analyzing humor is like dissecting
a frog few people are interested and the
Frog dies of it however of course people
still dissect frogs because some people
are interested and unlike the dissection
of a frog arguably the outcome of
looking into the nature of humor reveals
something beautiful of course there are
many different types of comedy stand-up
comedy comedy films theater music
literature commonplace conversational
humor and so on furthermore there are
many subgenres within each category of
comedy however what's interesting is
what seemingly strings them all together
the ingredients of a comedic occurrence
and the gravitational pull that we all
feel towards it there are several
theories on the nature of humor and what
makes a funny thing funny
however one of if not the primary and
most popularly accepted theory is known
as the incongruity theory simply put the
incongruity theory suggests that
something is funny when one realizes a
difference between what is expected and
what actually happens a discrepancy
between a person's concept of a thing
and their perceptual experience of the
thing when both are supposed to go
together but don't this theory was
proposed accepted and discussed by
renowned philosophers like James Beattie
Immanuel Kant Arthur Schopenhauer and
Soren Kierkegaard in reference to this
principle Kierkegaard said man is the
only animal that laughs and weeps for he
is the only animal that is struck with
the difference between what things are
and what they ought to be coinciding
with the incongruity theory 21st century
behavioral scientist Peter McGraw
crafted a theory known as the benign
violation theory
in which it is suggested that humor is
found when a violation or disruption of
one's expectations or sense of normality
occurs but more specifically only when
the violation is felt as benign in other
words the violation does not cause any
real harm to the person perceiving it
this of course means that one sense of
humor is relative to their perception of
how the world is or ought to be as well
as their perception of what is harmful
or offensive within it regardless of the
relativity of one sense of humor
generally everyone's returns to the same
principle of experiencing something
unexpected irrational or incongruent
which begs the question why is it that
when something goes wrong when something
is close to being painful or when
something dupes the rational mind do we
experience it as funny and pleasurable
it is in the nature of the human being
to take him or herself fairly seriously
a human is both consciously and
rationally aware of itself and so what
option is there other than to be
conscious and rational about itself in
its existence however the experience of
something humorous confronts us with the
realization that our logic and
sensibility is at least in the instance
inadequate or incongruent with reality
that we didn't and couldn't know what
was going to happen on the other side of
the joke or comedic occurrence 20th
century existentialist philosopher
Albert Camus writes man stands face to
face with the irrational he feels within
him is longing for happiness and for
reason the absurd is born of this
confrontation between the human need and
the unreasonable silence of the world
and so how does a rational being
confront the idea that its existence
might not be rational but rather absurd
perhaps the answer is simply to laugh we
all share in the same susceptibility of
being wrong and coming face to face with
the apparently unknowable in different
conditions of the universe the ultimate
comedian is life itself as it
apathetically mocks our attempts to put
our foot on it no matter our attempts to
attribute meaning to existence no matter
any one sense of truth it is fair to
argue that the only truth anyone can
ever be sure of is that they can't be
sure of their own truth and perhaps it
is obligatory here to say that this
might not even be true regardless the
point is there is an inherent longing
for certainty in human life a longing
that manifests itself in all kinds of
ridiculous ways ways that can be harmful
misleading or despairing humor helps us
counterbalance this it helps us lighten
up a little when we fall too deeply into
ourselves as individuals and as
collectives it helps us realize things
aren't always as they seem
nor as serious it reminds us of how
little we know about what might happen
next and that we shouldn't think to
pompously of oneself or live with too
cold or too rigid of beliefs that claim
ultimate power or certainty and the
absurdity of life it shows us that we're
all pretty goofy and foolish but that
that's ok and that we should share in
the laughter rather than fight over the
despair interestingly many philosophers
of the past including some of the
aforementioned negatively critiqued
humors role in the human condition
Immanuel Kant argued that the joy of
laughter is purely physical rather than
intellectual he posed the question that
if to be human is to be rational and
seek rational understanding how could it
be positive to realize and experience
the irrational however if in fact we do
exist in an absurd relationship with the
universe is it not a value that we can
and do transmute the absurdity into
playfulness enjoyable miss and Happiness
is that not the most rational thing left
to do the role of the comedian is no
different than the artist or the
philosopher the filmmaker or the
musician to turn the mundane into the
exciting the bleak into the enjoyable
the confusing into the discernible and
to help us better consider and adapt our
perspectives of the world with sincerity
and honesty only possible to the medium
perhaps not all comedy and humor can be
seen as positive but fundamentally in
every well-intended comedic moment there
exists an attempt to transmute the
conscious experience of the absurd and
chaotic into something pleasurable
earnest playful clever or interesting
and in every experience of laughter we
are reminded of how foolish we are but
how joyful we can be nonetheless
this video was sponsored by Skillshare
before saying anything further about
Skillshare it's important to quickly
reiterate that all sponsors on this
channel do not affect the content or
topics covered furthermore all brands
and products promoted are filtered in
order to ensure that they are
considerate of you the viewer and might
provide real value with that Skillshare
is this video sponsor if you aren't
familiar Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills skills shares
unique curated source of information can
help you more easily learn about new
subjects better understand various
skills or assist you in the development
of your career with an annual
subscription cost of less than $10 a
month Skillshare is very affordable
especially when considered against
higher priced in-person classes and
workshops it is also worth knowing that
a Premium Membership gives you unlimited
access so you can join any in all of the
classes and communities that might be of
interest specifically an excellent
course on creative writing and
storytelling entitled creative writing
essentials writing standout opening
scenes is a very accessible yet
intelligent thoughtful course available
on Skillshare in which the course
instructor Danielle Jose older shares a
peek into his writing and editing
process as he navigates through one of
his published novels shadow shaper
contrasting the first draft from the
final draft showcasing what improvements
were required along the way the course
provides helpful considerations of
things related to seeing construction
and character development especially in
terms of the opening scene of a story if
writing is at all of interest this
course is one worth checking out because
Skillshare is sponsoring this video
there is a link in the description to
sign up for a two month free trial of
course thanks so much for watching and
see you next video
[Music]